this is the man who's engineered some of
the biggest recent breakthroughs in the
technology of artificial limbs after a
mountaineering accident cue her went
through a double amputation and decided
to dedicate his life's work to finding a
better solution for people who need
prosthetics he believes the answer is in
bionics i define bionics as design
structures either from synthetics or
biologic materials that internally
connect or implanted inside the body
that at least normalized human
physiological function and from time to
time actually extend human capability
these limbs can do things that no other
commercially available prosthetics can
the foot ankle that I'm wearing is the
first Bionic ankle that is powered that
that emulates lost muscle function all
other commercial foot ankle devices are
human powered like a bicycles human
powered where only your energy causes
the bicycle move this technology has now
been spun out from MIT into a startup
called bionics the company has already
fitted 1300 patients with these limps
fifty percent of them wounded veterans a
new partnership with otto bock the
world's largest prosthetics maker will
mean patients across Western Europe can
access this technology the bio
mechatronics lab is also developing
exoskeletons equipment that could
augment human physical performance
beyond what nature intended enhancing
performance for athletes and soldiers
helping the weak or the elderly walk and
making extreme sports even more
thrilling I think in the very near
future you walk down the streets of New
York or Boston and it'll be common to
see people wearing bionics bionics is
about self-improvement it's about a
journey of what humanity can be
when humanity blends and integrates with
a good good technology good design